[Music]
hello, how are you, Salí Jaramillo greets you
for your brief informative for today, Tuesday
, September 28, more than a decade after the
murder of a local teenager, the
last suspect in the case will hear
his sentence today, Dave en Polop, will
appear before a judge.  Today he was one
of four men accused of
killing 16-year-old Rivero at a party
inside a residence in 2009, and
police are on the trail of
a shooting suspect after they
sparked a fatal fight inside a
laundromat.  this happened a little
after eight o'clock at night in front of
the boulevard shopping center near
turin and mermen parkway authorities
revealed that three men were
involved in this fight when two
pulled out firearms and started
shooting one man died in hospital
but it is not yet known if he was one of those
who started the shooting
starting today several
pharmacies will be offering the
booster vaccine against  To be eligible for the cubit,
you must be over 65 years of age.
Adults can obtain it if they
have
pre-existing medical conditions, those who have a
job that is exposed to
contracting the virus and sections that
apply for all information, you can
visit our page at  news now
dotcom the section in Spanish and now
we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a sunny day reaching a
temperature of 89 degrees but we will be back
in the 90s by the weekend
the winds return to the valley by this afternoon it
could feel a little cooler
nice day  sal y jaramillo salutes you and
this was your just
out briefing in Spanish
[Music]